Yeah.
And the,
you know,
people say,
okay,
it's a right,
but obviously there's a problem,
so we have to do something about it.
So you're going to have to give up your guns.
This is,
this is the common conversation and it's very flippant and it's not well thought
out and there's no con no consideration whatsoever to mental health issues.
I think Kickstarter,
this is Marcus.
I think that's the primary problem.
I,
that's,
I've been saying this from the get go.
I think it's the primary problem.
I think it's a mental health issue and people say,
oh,
that's simplifying it.
I don't think it is.
I think it's the opposite.
I think it's,
it's ignored.
Yeah.
It's,
there's something wrong when you have this many people on mental health
medication.
And then when you look at the number of bash shooters,
it's almost universal.
Almost every single one of them is on some sort of psychiatric medication.
But that's not a part of the narrative.
That's not a part of the conversation.
The conversation is always get rid of guns.
Now,
I don't want crazy people to have guns.
I don't think you do either.
No,
don't.
So
outside of taking away the rights to have guns from normal law abiding people
like yourself and myself,
I have guns.
What?
What do we do?
Okay,
so first of all,
I think we need to frame the conversation into specifics,
right?
You're a lawyer,
I am.
Okay.
You understand bills and amendments and law.
Yeah.
And so I think one word lumping the entire conversation into one category,
right?
If we're going to talk about school shootings,
let's talk about school shootings.
Okay.
Right?
So the first thing I say is,
because one thing a lot of people on this I'd like to say is,
well,
you guys just don't want any,
any gun laws,
and you say no to everything,
but you have no solutions to just stand up for that.
It's because all they want to do is take away the guns.
Yeah.
They,
they're saying,
let's take away the guns.
Just saying,
we're not going to take away the guns.
You guys just don't want to get your guns taken away.
Yes,
you're right.
No one wants to get their guns take away.
And then I get laid with a monster as a result of saying exactly,
you want kids to die and it's a fucking real sneaky conversations.
Disingenuine success.
It is.
And that's the odd thing about it is it's you.
Anybody who's paying attention to the discourse,
in a way it's happening,
especially on social media,
right?
Anybody who follows my Twitter,
my Twitter account gnosis multiple occasions.
I've tried to have a rational conversation with people who are on the complete
opposite side of my spectrum of,
of,
of this issue.
Is there any of this online?
They're like debates or anything like that?
Well,
no,
I mean it's just on Twitter tweets going back and you can't do anything rational
on Twitter.
You can occasionally you can send it to God.
They're miracle.
That is a clown heart.
People being friendly.
You want to see me,
flustered,
respond to me rationally
cause I'm always,
you know,
I have this guard up.
Right,
right.
Of course.
And I actually had to check myself about that a little bit because how am I any
better than the people on the other side?
If I had the same at the same energy that they have towards me,
that's a very good point.
And so I've started,
you know what,
let me,
cause I can be incredibly snarky,
like I can't.
Um,
and it's partly due because of my friends.
They're all assholes.
They're just like all the friends I grew up with.
I grew up arguing with a group of guys who when they were losing it logically,
they went to jokes.
Right,
right.
And then a man pretty much,
It took me a second to realize it cause I was the one that law school,
right.
I was the one that was going to law school,
pre law,
all that stuff.
So everything I did was focused and centered through the idea of logic,
logic,
logic.
You're not making any sense.
And then I'll crack a joke and everyone's laughing and I realized there's some
power to that.
Right.
You know,
humor.
I mean,
you should know something about that.
Just a little for sure.
Yeah.
And so I took on some of those qualities in a way that I advocate for firearms,
you know,
because it can be a little disarming.
But the disarming aspect of it can be beneficial because it causes people to
drop their guard a little bit.
And then when you drop your guard,
you can take in information more objectively,
more so than waiting or looking for confirmation bias or instigating your
cognitive dissonance because you just don't want to hear the thing that con
that's contrary to what you already believe.
I just think you need a lot of character,
like as a person to be able to communicate reasonably on Twitter.
And there's a lot of people that are just lacking that.
So it's almost like the ability to steal and no one's looking.
The ability to just shit on someone with no eye to eye contact,
no social repercussions.
No.
You know,
you're not feeling anything from that person.
You say something rude to them,
they're not in front of you,
so don't feel terrible saying it.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
I'm not gonna lie.
So Twitter isn't dirty place.
It's a dirty place,
but it's a great place to,
sometimes it is.